People still need help Dad that's why we made this
it's like a satellite for deep
space but Quanta it's amazing
where are we
this place
it isn't what you think
I can get you home
and give you more time if you help me
so what you gonna be ant-man.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel released
a new trailer for Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania so
we'll break it down there's a whole bunch of stuff
going up they are using it to set up Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty they said that was meant to be a
big difference from the previous Ant-Man movies
the director wanted this movie to be like a big
Avengers level movie as opposed to the previous
Ant-Man movies which were released right after big
Avengers movies like Avengers Age of Ultron and
Avengers Infinity war and started Moore's palette
cleansers if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos I will do
a special giveaway for movie tickets when we get
a little bit closer to the movie actually coming
out the music that they're using on the trailer
is Elton John's Goodbye Yellow Brick Road because
they're treating the quantum realm like the Land
of Oz which I guess makes Kang The Wizard of
Oz in this scenario the difference being that
in The Wizard of Oz movie The Wizard was just
pretending to be a wizard he was a normal person
who was lying to the people there thinking that
it would help him survive even though it didn't
sound like he needed to do that in Ant-Man 3 Kang
is still every bit as powerful as he claims to be
like it's still very much Kang the Conqueror
he's not lying about that the big thing he's
lying about to all these people and to Ant-Man
is that he's a friend being benevolent helping
rule over them who wants to help Ant-Man and
the others get back to the normal world like
he tells him in the trailer I can help you get
more time when really he's meant to be one of
the worst Kang variants there is we're still
gonna see a bunch of different variants of Kang
across the Marvel Phase 5 Marvel Phase 6 movies
you also may have detected that there's a bunch
of Kang variants hiding in the background too
because of the big twist that they included in
the trailer with ant-man's character in a bunch
of his variants like an army of ant men there's
also an army of Kangs in there too we will see
a version of the Council of kangs in the movies
eventually I'll explain how they're going to
do that though because I think they're going
to save some of that for Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
where the Avengers do wind up having to fight a
bunch of different versions of Kang from across
the Multiverse but basically what happened to
the characters after Avengers end game is that
Scotland became famous because of his role in
Avengers end game saving the world everybody loves
him they had the whole joke about the little kid
having the Ant-Man merch like that's how famous
he's become but also the world still knows about
Spider-Man who's way more famous which is why the
shop owner calls him Spider-Man like oh thanks so
much even though that's totally not me that's
totally another guy they weren't really clear
about it in the trailer but hope Van Dyne has
also become famous too and she started to use Pym
particles to solve world hunger like literally
just growing the food in third world countries
larger in size so the whole idea is that when
the movie picks up things are meant to be going
great for them for the most part with a couple
exceptions we've seen during some of the Marvel
phase 4 projects that not all the Avengers are
doing great after Avengers end game like some are
still experiencing a whole bunch of trauma like
winter soldier some like Falcon can't even get a
bank loan for the most part the Ant-Man characters
are meant to be doing amazing with the exception
of Cassie Lang so the whole idea is that when
the movie picks up Scott Lang doing great like
everything seems like it's going so well for
him and his family but he winds up getting a
call from the police station in San Francisco
Cassie Lang has been arrested because she got
herself in trouble while she was just messing
round even though they have recast the actress
the whole idea is that during the five-year time
Jump she became something of a scientist as well
she's meant to be a teenager a little bit older
now she's turned into the Stinger version of the
character that suit is just a little bit different
and that it's a little bit more like the wasp's
costume usually when you think of Cassie Lang in
the comics you think of the stature version of
her character where she becomes more like giant
woman I think the reason why they went with the
Stinger version of her character in the movie
is because they wanted that power set versus the
giant woman power set and they wanted the purple
costume versus the red costume they didn't want
to be too much like ant-man's costume but Cassie
Lane getting arrested is meant to be a parallel
for Scott Lang being arrested it's meant to be one
of those situations where the apple does not fall
far from the tree and if it wasn't clear Scott
Lang even though most people just remember him
being a thief he's also meant to be really smart
like he's not quite as smart as Hank Pym or like
Tony Stark but before he became a thief he was an
engineer so like he does understand Pym particles
he does know the technical aspects of how all
this stuff works it's just that all the movies
have been treating him in a very a comedic way
giving him all these jokes so that people forget
that he's actually a super smart person before
we start let me address you know I've heard a lot
I didn't shrink down go in and uh kill Thanos in
a really creative way first of all gross secondly
it's much more complicated than that it's meant
to be kind of the same Vibe with Cassie Lang like
she is also very smart she's become an engineer
in this five-year time Jump but just like Scott
Lang gets herself into all kinds of trouble which
is basically how they set off the whole plot of
the movie with her creating the special Quantum
device that sends a signal to the quantum realm
that's meant to be more like a distressed Beacon
but then Kang uses to pull them back in to help
him escape the reason why she's messing with
Quantum technology why Janet Van Dyne gets so
pissed off at her is because during the five-year
time Jump she was reading a lot of Hank pym's
journals learning about Quantum technology and
that's how she engineered this special device is
that apparently all the journals that she was
reading didn't include all the dangers of the
quantum realm which is what they explained with
Jana Van Dyne says there's something I didn't tell
you in the something that she didn't tell them was
was about her history with Kang the Conqueror the
whole idea is that when she was stranded to the
quantum realm is that she met Nathaniel Richards
before she knew who he really was and what he was
capable of he was a human from Earth but had been
aligned to her about his identity now he got
stuck there because he came from the distant
future and it was a very Wizard of Oz kind of
scenario so if you remember in The Wizard of
Oz movie The Wizard got stuck in Oz because his
balloon basically crashed stranding him there it's
kind of the same deal with Kang the Conqueror his
original time ship crashed in the quantum realm
and because of the way that it crashed he wasn't
able to fix it easily that's why I think they had
this whole plot twist with him forcing Ant-Man
to help get something from the ship so that he
can escape something about the way that his time
ship crashed created this really weird Nexus of
energies that he himself just can't easily access
like I think the reason why he needs Scott Lang
to do it is because he'll die if he tries or he's
worried that he'll die because in this scene where
you see a bunch of ant men a bunch of different
variants of Ant-Man running you you see a bunch
of them dying while it's happening too you also
see him flying in one of Kang's ships towards this
wreckage of a ship which seems like his original
ship that crashed when they're inside of it it
seems like reality all around here is broken like
you see this red energy arcing where it seems like
reality literally has cracked open and I think
the whole idea is that Janet Van Dyne eventually
learned his secret like oh you're actually Kang
the Conqueror who wants to conquer all of reality
every single Multiverse using the quantum realm
and that's why you got stuck here because you were
trying to find a way to do that she eventually
escapes during the events of Ant-Man the Wasp
but then in that time Jump since then Kang has
been searching for a way to get out and detects
Cassie Lang's signal it's like all right I'm
gonna use that so he's more like the evil Wizard
of Oz this is also where I think things cross
over with the events of Loki season 2 because
Loki season 2 is meant to come out right after
Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania so like we see Kang
the Conqueror in the Loki season one post-credits
scene but the report is is that during the events
of Loki season 2 when Loki is trying to reveal
the truth of Kang to all these people who don't
seem to remember him because remember the timeline
rebooted so Mobius Hunter B15 all the other agents
here at the TVA don't know what's actually going
on during the Loki season 2 trailer you see him
trying to re-explain the events of season 1 to
everyone again particularly Mobius he reveals
Kang's face here they have a bunch of Easter eggs
for earlier versions of Kang in his timeline but
apparently during the Loki season 2 Kang isn't
around like he isn't actually physically at the
TVA even though it seems like he is like you see
his Visage you see statues of him pictures of
him all over the place I think the idea is that
he's missing quote unquote during the events of
Loki season 2 or at least at the beginning of
the series because he got stuck in the quantum
realm remember because of the way the time works
it's possible for him to have created the TVA and
win the kang Multiverse war or start winning it
then get stuck in the quantum realm then meet a
version of Janet Van Dyne and just be stuck
in there for a while and because of the way
the time moves differently in the quantum realm
it seems like he's been stuck there for for way
longer when in reality he's only been stuck in
there for a couple years and the whole idea is
that he survives Ant-Man the wassey survives the
events of the movie to actually escape and go on
to the events of Avengers Kang Dynasty like he
completes his mission and is able to eventually
collapse the Multiverse into one single Universe
which is where we get to Avengers Secret Wars and
that'll be their sort of Thanos snap Infinity
Gauntlet kind of Downer ending for Avengers
Kang Dynasty like oh he actually succeeded what
are we going to do about that how are we going
to save all of reality one of the other really
cool rumors about Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty is that
during it you have like a couple of new Avengers
that will form during Captain America 4 New World
Order during Marvel phase five remember Avengers 5
Avengers 6 don't come till Marvel phase six during
Captain America 4 Falcon starts putting together
a version of The New Avengers team because we
have a couple of them that have shown up during
Marvel phase four and a couple more will come
along during Marvel Phase 5 but when Avengers 5
Kane Dynasty picks up a little while later those
Avengers wind up getting their asses kicked by
Kang the Conqueror and his variants just like
Thanos rolled over all the Avengers in Avengers
Infinity War like Thanos actually won that movie
he was able to form and snap The Infinity Gauntlet
Kang will wind up wiping the floor with the new
Avengers during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in the
whole idea during Infinity war and endgame is
a doctor strange found like that one chance in
14 million where they were able to beat him but
in order to do that they had to lose the battle
in Avengers Infinity War so that they could win
the actual war in Avengers end game and what'll
happen when Avengers 6 Secret Wars picks up is
that in order to win the War Doctor Strange and
whoever else is with him will wind up looking to
the Multiverse to build a Multiverse Avengers team
that will be able to beat king the Conqueror Lego
the 616 Main MCU Avengers weren't enough we need
to find more badass Avengers from the Multiverse
and that's where you get all your cameos from like
the fox Marvel movies you get like Hugh Jackman
Wolverine being on a version of The Avengers you
get a Multiverse version of Iron Man Robert Downey
Jr coming back to play a different version of the
character just like the most badass version of The
Avengers that you could think of from any version
of the comics any version of the movies the
Animated Series anything you also get Toby Maguire
and Andrew Garfield coming back to Cameo being on
a version of that Multiverse Avengers there's a
lot of other stuff going on during Ant-Man and
the Wasp they haven't totally got into a lot of
the MODOKand a lot of the Bill Murray stuff that's
like a completely separate part of the movie
we'll probably see some more footage for them
when we get more trailers in the next month if you
spotted any other Easter eggs in the trailer that
I didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments like I said more footage
coming really soon there's a bunch of trailers
that'll be dropping this week for other stuff too
so make sure you enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that in happy holidays to everyone
click here for my new Loki season 2 trailer video
and click here for that Henry Cavill Warhammer
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!